- Hold it, hold,
now!
- [Pie Guys] Oh!
- You got crazy
lungs, Apocalypto!
- Yeah, I can hit
(garbled speech)
- I don't know
what you're saying!
(all laugh)
- Hey, hey,
you guys ever do coke?
- What?
- They said they'd never
seen a lower LSAT score.
- What'd you get?
- 90.
- That's an A.
- A minus.
- That's not how that works.
- Guys, where's Sal?
It's the lunch rush,
we have three orders.
- Who?
- Salvatore, our head cook?
Giant Oaxacan, you
ever heard of him?
- Oh, Apocalypto.
- Oh.
I didn't know his
name has Salvatore.
- I didn't know he was Italian.
- It's fine, dude,
he's right here.
(horn honks)
- Oh my god.
- He's fixing my horn.
Sounds good, buddy!
Good work.
- Oh no, he's the only
decent cook we have!
Who wants out?
Ow, ow my arm!
(techno theme music)
- So he rear-ends me,
gets out of his car,
it's Beau Bridges.
Could not have been nicer guy.
- I saw Randy Quaid
at Wendy's once.
- Hey what's up Jacinda?
Guess how many perfect
push-ups I did this morning.
Almost 30.
- Cool, can't wait
to tell my boyfriend.
- Oh, progress.
- Pretty good.
- Yeah.
- Guys, this is
getting out of hand.
- What's getting out of hand?
- I may look like an idiot,
but I'm not an idiot, John.
Smells like Bob Marley's
butt-hole all over this place.
- Uh, so it smells like shit?
- No.
Weed.
- Then why does he say it
smells like a butt-hole.
- That's why I said Bob Marley.
You know, he smoked
a lot of weed.
- I think what Mort's saying
is that it's still a butt hole
so it smells like shit,
no matter whose butt-hole it is.
- My cats only eat cat food,
but their butt holes
still smell like shit.
- You smell your
cat's butt-hole?
- No, I just wake up in the
morning and they're like,
kind of around my face.
- Hey, what kind of
cats do you have again?
- A orange tabby and a Burmese.
- Oh, cute.
- [Mort] It is.
- Guys!
I mean look what you did to Sal.
- That's called
a siesta, Samuel.
Okay, it's part of his culture.
What are you, a racist?
- What, no!
- [] Sound a little racist.
- Guys.
(Mort babbles)
My office.
Now!
That's it guys, no more smoking.
- What?
That's insane.
It's basically part of our job.
Guys, back me up.
- I'll stop.
- You're a coward,
always have been.
- Samuel, if I'm
being totally honest.
- Only be honest if
it's agreeing with me.
- It doesn't make me more
focused at work, but,
there are a lot of studies
that show happy employees
are more productive
than unhappy employees.
- See, Samuel, studies.
Dude, you hate your job.
- I don't hate my job.
- We hear you
crying in here, man.
- Last week we heard
you call yourself
a divorced pile of shit.
- I was reading an article.
(Sal groans)
What, no, Sal.
Sal.
- Oh, no no no no.
- [Samuel] I'm in a meeting!
Go, go into the parking lot.
- Look at what you
have to deal with!
You should be high at work.
- I can't get high.
- What do you mean
you can't get high?
- I tried when I was in college
and nothing happened to me.
Pot wasn't that big at Brown
when I was there anyway.
- Whoa, is that an
Ivy League school?
- More importantly
you can't get high?
- No.
♪ Let's smoke
- I can't believe how
long he's holding it.
- I have to do
something with my life.
- He's over three minutes,
now!
(all cheer)
Oh my god, he's pissing!
Oh!
Gross, gross.
♪ Hydro turbo
kush, feeling right
♪ Kush in the air,
blowing smoke everywhere
(techno theme music)